nous en quarts
moi ça fait quatre ans m je crois pas
aux roms un peu profité 4 il ya moins 3
degrés là et là on va chercher des gels
hydro alcooliques pour nous chauffer là
demain on va faire comme ça même pas dix
minutes on a en beauté justement de
caumont
hélas les titres comme ça là à l'ancien
comment la guerre comme à la guerre et
voilà c'est parti
on accuse les zones où tout à l'heure on
a des effets non j'ai fait comme ça on a
l'eau qui bout et après on a des yeux
durs pour moi je dise
douglas souffre
maverick on sera sorti
mais là ça y est
après le droit chemin
il
l'aide pour survivre on a commencé à
faire ça à 17h38 la neige elle arrive de
chaleur dont on appréhende on n'est pas
bien là mais on craint alors là c'est
juste qu'on fait c'est on prend les
couvertures nous colle et on ne bouge
plus qu'on a des mauvaises positions des
mauvaises positions au début de la rue
si rien
mais après au bout de quelques années là
oui parce que tes muscles et comprennent
pas pourquoi depuis toujours figé tu
vois
ça lui fait du bien aux muscles nerfs
les bras je sors l'association ela la
sadc du pays ici et là ça lui fait du
bien à parfumer n'ont pu lui non plus on
a envie de tous d'arrêter l'alcool on
veut pas boire on veut plus bois mais
parce que en fait c'est on veut pas
boire c'est parce que on a mal on a
tellement mal donc pour pas avoir froid
est là qu'est ce qu'on fait et par 111
voix pour réchauffer les veines et les
muscles et c'est une spirale du team
spirale en
très compliqué allumez le feu j'aime
bien j'ai appris des trucs comme gabriel
et tout le monde espère maintenant match
de barrage autre chose que bah voilà
comment bien au final chaque jour on
essaie de trouver une petite astuce une
petite solution pour s'en sortir et
c'est un combat
ça c'est les cartons par le feu dans les
cheveux ça c'est des sacs d'hygiène est
loué les vides des vêtements mouillés
humide il faut les laver pour quatre
offres
combien de couches de laque les
vêtements la pleure pas combien de
couches de maintenant du coup j'en ai un
2 froid et avec ça j'ai froid